[Musik]
jede stadt die etwas auf sich hält hat
irgendwo auf ihre schattenseite eine
straße wo all das seinen platz findet
was an der schönen seepromenade
unerwünscht ist in luzern war das schon
immer die baselstrasse hierher zu hause
ist steht nicht im rampenlicht der
gesellschaft sondern führt wie die
straße selbst eher ein schattendasein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zur ausstattung
schön
der alltag in der baselstrasse ist für
den künstler christoph fischer die
quelle seiner inspiration
[Musik]
der asphalt vor seinem atelier ist für
ihn die bühne
auf welche der zufall täglich ein neues
theaterstück inszeniert
einer der hauptdarsteller in diesem
theater ist der pensionierte
straßenarbeiter heinz killy jeden tag
pünktlich um 18 uhr betritt er die bühne
immer dann wenn die neue gratis zeitung
am kiosk erscheint
heinz hat christoph zu einem neuen
projekt inspiriert auf dem kreuz sturz
soll ein kreisel kunstwerk entstehen
[Musik]
der gast beim abgang zum lesen aber
nicht mit der dorfgemeinschaft
dabei hatte ich noch in führung
dank sieben nationen russland froh so
ist die setzen sich zu wort die schwarze
bananen erklären wir hier
das lasse auf sich warten natürlichkeit
nicht der kommerz bananen garten die so
einiges vor sich
die nacht in der baselstrasse hat ihre
spuren hinterlassen sie zu beseitigen
ist für den hausbesitzer bizarren immer
wieder eine mühsame pflicht
si
wenn ich auto sektor sind aber die
dämpfe sind möglich geworden und steht
auf dem grundstück und ich bin
verantwortlich
ja leider
ich würde
weißt du da diese kurze beim haus
hingelegt
ich bekomme keine busse zu sprengen
dabei schnitten mit ja
wie prof
[Musik]
für ammann asse aus syrien ist die
baselstrasse ein ort der hoffnung
sie hat soeben einen positiven
asylbescheid bekommen und will sich eine
neue existenz aufbauen
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
vor 20 jahren hat das haus mit der
nummer 58 gekauft und mit viel
eigenarbeit renoviert
170 jahre hat das feuer bereits auf dem
buckel
heute beherbergt es eine bunte mischung
von mietern aus aller welt
ich muss das muss es auswärts so aus sie
nicht zu hause passieren einfach
hinstellt deponiert auch der schweizer
straßenmusiker daniele martin hat im
ausland eine bleibe gefunden so genau wo
sonst keine probleme wählt die haupt mit
karaoke mit keine probleme
also die große diese könnt ruhig einmal
gebraucht habe ich sie willkommen
gewesen
ja ja gut
außerdem komme ich mit dem tod das ist
diese typische familie später inzwischen
die sache christoph rella dann noch
verdankt inzwischen wenn die 40 jahre
besteht einfach besser da unten wieder
vor mir jedes flur allein schon jetzt so
gut wie heute letzte fiel der
winzerfamilie nominiert und wenn ich sie
nicht aus
besondere originalen zutrifft dass ich
mir nichts mit flatrate heile welt
trifft weiterhin zu ihr dass ich mich
nicht
tschuldigung dass ich mich mit wie heile
welt
wieso ist ein heiliger
die sogenannte monatsvertrag wichtig
laktose-intoleranz jedes mal wenn
priorität und schaue mir ist das ganze
programm der probieren
warum entwickeln was ich noch die stoffe
und alle dämme
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hier habe man nicht passiert bei diesen
möglich passiert außerdem legen sie sich
ständig da staune und jurke was ich
kaufen sondern
die meisten zu schaffen und sich bewegt
also wenn ich das mal den schwinger
hoffen mit dem geplanten kreisel
kunstwerk betritt der illustrator und
zeichner christoph künstlerisches
neuland bildhauerei ist eigentlich
nichts ein fachgebiet beispiel das
flugzeug am morgen vier gesetzt hätten
und er heute machen
[Musik]
die straßenschlucht am rande der stadt
luzern hat schon viele migrationswellen
aufgefangen
der volksmund hat ihr je nach
politischer weltlage immer wieder andere
namen gegeben
in den 60er jahren nannte man sie little
italy später hieß sie neu belgrad oder
mann bezeichnete sie gar als das ghetto
für viele luzern aber war die
baselstrasse einfach nur die rute
blamage
ich bin gut
[Musik]
eine wohnung in ja ich war so nicht 30
als größter wunsch ist es ihre durch den
syrischen bürgerkrieg auseinander
gerissene familie wieder zusammen zu
führen
ihren mann adnan hat die flucht aus
syrien nach prag verschlagen
ihre einzige tochter angela musste sie
in damaskus zurücklassen kannst du es
kein öffnen und mit mir reden ja kann
ich aber bald wird der strom abgestellt
dann machen wir ganz schnell
solange wir noch strom haben an seiner
ich kann an nichts anderes denken als
dass du endlich hier bist ich möchte
nicht dass du dir sorgen nicht
es ist unsere schuld du hast ja dein
leben nicht so ausgesucht sei es in
syrien oder in europa wir haben dich
dazu gezwungen
aber wir hatten keine wahl wir mussten
unsere heimat verlassen
wieso verurteilen sie uns als
terroristen
wir haben uns bloß für die vernunft
eingesetzt unser einziger fehler war
dass wir unsere meinung frei äußern
wollten
wir müssen deine flucht so planen wie
meine du musst die selbe route nehmen
wie ich mir ist wichtig dass du sicher
ankommst
ich denke an nichts anderes als dass du
endlich bei mir bist
als der bürgerkrieg in den straßen am
rande von damaskus wütete richtete amal
zusammen mit ihrem mann eine
krankenstation ein um verletzte zu
versorgen
sie wurde mehrmals verhaftet und ihre
tochter drängt er darauf dass ihre
eltern das land verlassen
die universitäten in damaskus inn zwar
offen aber das sind immer wieder
checkpoints und bei jedem kann man
verhaftet oder gedemütigt werden wenn
meine tochter von der uni nach hause kam
hatte sie jedes mal angst dass wir weg
sind und dass sie uns nie mehr wieder
sehen würde
als wir dann aus dem gefängnis kamen hat
sie uns angefleht das land zu verlassen
sie hielt die ständige angst um uns
nicht mehr aus ohne visum konnten wir
unsere tochter nicht mitnehmen
im libanon wollten wir sie nicht bleiben
lassen also ließen wir sie in syrien
zurück und beschlossen es später zu
versuchen die überraschung war dass die
schweiz keine familienzusammenführung
machen wollte da meine tochter schon
volljährig ist
jetzt versuchen wir über das rote kreuz
sein visum für sie zu bekommen damit wir
endlich wieder zusammen sind
[Musik]
das hat mir niemand wolle dass nächsten
rein ich will packt noch 17 uhr laden
ordnung wenn ich doch vielfach auf sutil
der sich nicht lieber wieder in der
retorte familie gründet uns hält an ich
nicht verloren wenn wir zusammen sind
denn es sind ja wenn ich in einer
leipziger oder geschweige denn mit
sicherheit auf dem balkon cora hat das
wird schon schwierig zum gefahren wäre
neben der gratis ist aber viele spieler
mit mehr
ja ja dass ich mich stolz
jetzt ist für ihre daher glaube ich
glaube so knabl aus erklärt
richter vom ried sturz vom kreis und
christoph fischer habe mit der vorletzte
woche trägt super perfekt ja der
abstimmung
ja es war für christoph nicht leicht
sich zu überwinden und heinz anzurufen
denn eine absage von heinz hätte seine
ganze vorarbeit in frage gestellt dass
ich die idee dass das drückt den wert
der welt
bewegung ist noch da sind noch schneller
verdaut
genauso wie ich
[Musik]
eigentlich darf
erst mal geschockt nach dem projekt
sehr gut
für maria york sein
mal
aber wir brauchen so schön
keine hat
diese hat
christoph wer den ehemaligen
straßenarbeiter möglichst naturgetreu in
beton gießen
zunächst baut ihr ein kleineres modell
aus styropor und gips
dass er dann auf die endgeräte kopieren
will mit hilfe einer von leonardo da
vinci erfundenen methode
ich habe extra ihn wählten sie sagen
einfach dem folgt der kleine mann oder
das nicht nicht abwarten einziger sowas
steht für einfache für eine generation
arbeiten hintergrund
[Musik]
sechs tage die woche und nimmt sie
taufen und nur jeder einzelne die ganz
posthum noch seine besucher
die geburt seines sohnes brachte viel
licht in das leben von daniela fast fünf
jahre lang lebte er drogenfrei und
kümmerte sich um den kleinen dann aber
platzte der traum einer familie und
daniele wurde wieder rückfällig
sein sohn wächst bei einer pflegefamilie
auf und wenn daniel es sich an die
amtlichen abmachungen hält kann er ihn
regelmäßig sehen
die nummer
[Musik]
die 2 neben ihnen machen
aber menschen
[Musik]
ausgedacht nicht stütze ich spiele gern
aus einem fenster das gut mache
ganz wenig sparen das wird nicht freuen
[Musik]
wieso und sowieso
entdeckt
[Musik]
in ordnung des 20 50 franken
worum handelt wir zuletzt gefallen hat
dank kirche wohin geht macht sich sorgen
um daniele seine post ist schon wieder
liegen geblieben
ja danke danke
die situation in der 58 entwickelt sich
langsam aber sicher zu einem echten
problem
einige mieter haben sich beschwert dass
in der waschküche drogensüchtige
übernachten
[Musik]
aber das ist natürlich so viel wie und
uns gemacht
das hat das spricht sich herum sondern
sind häufig ihren dienst auf
während christoph den körper von heinz
mit gips und beton neu erschafft wird
heinz mit seiner eigenen vergänglichkeit
konfrontiert das ist ja dann noch einen
drauf und der kopf verteilte schritten
ich mache da zieht es die ich seit ihr
sofort mit dem zynismus
[Musik]
ja
vor kurzem hat daniele in der 58 einen
feuerwehreinsatz verursacht
wahrscheinlich eine vergessen gegangene
zigarette pitt hat keine andere wahl
daniele verliert seine wohnung
auto zulegt sollte müssten wir dann
sollten
[Musik]
das haben sie sich gestern bleibt diesen
geräten oder und politischen rückschlag
punkt ist natürlich ein grund also die
tablets natürlich langsam gefährlich es
ist ja im prinzip tragisch sind also
fragte ich dass ich glaube dass ich
bleiben also wir sind anliegen um strom
[Musik]
ich bin ganz ohne wohnung
das heißt es geht der report etf jede
marke der schlafsack deponieren und am a
big bow wolle zum laufen
daniele muss seine schlafplätze von
nacht zu nacht wechseln um das risiko
einer strafanzeige möglichst klein zu
halten
klatschnass frenster weltkrieg sie
draußen von und alles mögliche dauer
risiko das eine habe der platz kann
erklärte von innen zu erkunden oder
gezeigt das problem sehen da mixa bei
dir war kein kontakt zu therapieren aber
es hat mir viel zitierte verwaltung
meint der sänger von denen ja wenn die
frauen das machen wir das gewachsen
an
hallo wie geht's dir internet probleme
auch in prag nicht nur in syrien dazu
wenig ab ich habe versucht mit angelo zu
reden aber sie schläft wonach sie leitet
sie gefeiert und ging zu spät ins bett
die schlechten zeiten haben und
hoffentlich bald ein ende
und wie sieht es eigentlich mit der
wohnsituation aus ich suche immer noch
aber es bringt nichts
stell dir vor all diese formulare
es ist so kompliziert hoffentlich gibt
es eine lösung
hauptsache wir sind bald zusammen wenn
wir als familie zusammen sind finden wir
eine wohnung die caritas wird uns helfen
trotzdem bin ich immer am suchen es ist
ganz schlimm
ich suche seit acht monaten ich weiß
nicht wie weit
doch sieben verschiedene friseure haben
im ladenlokal von pete bereits ihr glück
versucht jetzt präsentiert der somalias
abi galli seine neue geschäftsidee
[Musik]
vielleicht haben diese verlange kein
fleisch fleisch
der 1
der schaft intensivstation sie lang oder
und hämisch rücksetzers miteinander
hätten dürfte und den ich habe platz
innerhalb des dringend ist sie mit dem
herrn tumoren hatte ich im spittaler
nachgefragt und 30 immer noch die
intensiv-station ja das ist klar brachte
dramatisch da an schien dabei setzt also
das sind so heike dann schien da nicht
erwartet dass etwas dem wiedererwachen
sind überbrachte branche sie erfreuten
ja steigende druck brachte
bodensee
[Musik]
ich weiß dass ich noch so gut
einfach so ruhig wie mehr gesehen nicht
die briefe der schwerste schritt
[Musik]
schon wenige tage nach der operation hat
mannheims wieder nach hause entlassen
kurras wurde das projekt protestieren
vor dass dies das ja oder nein sage ich
wenn ich könnte würde ich nicht antreten
[Musik]
ich habe einen riesenaufwand ddr stand
rief die bankrotte die hätte richtige
haben und auch das tvt wolf ist noch nie
gut und gut und
eurosport ist noch nicht gut und haben
gut und teuer sind noch nicht
die tore sind noch nicht gut es geht
überall sache ist besser sie und so
nicht machen zufrieden und es wegen der
punkt finden im bundesrat sich gut aber
ja heinz hat inzwischen einen platz in
einem pflegeheim auf der sonnenseite der
stadt gefunden an seine auferstehung auf
dem kreisel glaubt ihr nicht mehr nicht
richtig machen möglich machen hat der
gleichstellung musste
hält die schöne bauern oder besonders
dunkel nicht versöhnt
angela ist mit dem auto von damaskus zur
libanesischen grenze gefahren
wir haben ihr ein auto mit einem fahrer
organisiert stunden lang wartete ich auf
ihren anruf ich wollte wissen ob sie das
land verlassen konnte aber sie ging
nicht ans telefon
als ich sie endlich erreicht er sagte
sie mir sie müsse nach damaskus zurück
die grenzbeamten hatten ihr verboten zu
ihrer familie zu gehen
jetzt müssen wir schauen ob es für sie
einen anderen weg gibt syrien zu
verlassen
[Musik]
dann komme ich aus meinem tatsächlich
richtung danke dort musik sich wichtige
und der umwelt zugute pixel weil ich die
techno hätte hätte wohl protestiert mit
dem spiel und mehr spiele
da was man nicht denkt sie nicht liebt
mich ob ich für ihn glauben wichtig
geforscht aus als von mir
so würden
erzählungen
somit war helmut gemacht und natürlich
der große sitze aber geschenkt der
amtsverwaltung und ist noch weg aber
beliebt sich ein junge
[Musik]
nach langen verhandlungen durch die
damals man von prag aus in die schweiz
einreisen
die baselstrasse hat jetzt zumindest die
eltern dieser syrischen familie vereint
[Musik]
die
obwohl ihm steckt in diesen filmen kenne
ja mit kosten von bleiben
[Musik]
zu
eines tages dann in der abenddämmerung
geschieht das womit fast keiner mehr
gerechnet hat am kreisel steht alles
bereit für das lang ersehnte wunder
die rüge blamage bekommt ihr neues
wahrzeichen
[Musik]
kann
wir glauben dass
[Musik]
noch genug
der frucht was du willst du siehst du es
geht
ich will doch dankbar
doch unter druck
ich bin jetzt oder nie hier darum
bereits gegen krieg und auf mio
der aufruf im raum